this piece we have voiceover actors for
big fans of Dragon Quest so wait to see
who we've got in our upcoming
announcements so next I have today
another title turn Alex please watch the
video
hello it is great to be here for the
first time I am director of Dragon Quest
builders and my name is Nina I'm very
happy to be able to share with you some
information about Dragon Quest builders
the clip that you have just seen is the
promotional video for Dragon Quest
builders and you were the first ones to
see them with this title we have
challenged ourselves to go into a new
genre called block making RPG and this
game takes place in a lifeguard the same
setting as the 1i have created 30 years
ago for the original dragon quest the
whole world is made with blocks in this
game and you can create whatever you
like using these blocks and the theme is
to restore the kingdom that has fallen
under the control of the Dragon Lord yes
and development of Dragon Quest builders
is progressing as an in-house project
over square enix so we are getting a lot
of ideas from mr. hoodie to make an
internet authentic dragon quest which
can be enjoyed by everyone feeling
reassured that I thought of that dick
one yes I'm like a spurt of this so I've
been saying asking for a lot of favors
but they've been very compliant with me
and I think it's going to create a great
game yes and we're getting great ideas
from him and we're doing their best to
make it into even a better one we taking
his ideas and we have also brought with
us another surprise today so can we do
this is it out
so we wanted to announce you the sale
date of this product it's going to be
launched on january twenty 8 2016 very
soon and we're working extremely hard to
release this piece and in the Tokyo Game
Show which will start from the day after
tomorrow we have prepared quite a unique
stage different than usual so we would
like to ask you to stop by our booth the
development team is working diligently
to challenge into this new genre with
dragon quest you might think that this
game is very difficult to control n to
maneuver but I think we have entered
into a very simple easy to use a game so
please come by the booth and try it
yourselves and of course Dragon Quest 11
the one that you might pay attention to
of course that is in progress of all so
please look forward to it as well thank
you so much